êt-vous pour les cheveux courts ou pour
les cheveux longs les cheveux demi longs
demi longs pourquoi demi longs j'aime
les cheveux très longs mais enfin je ne
veux pas couper le mien vous ne voulez
pas couper les BR non pour l'instant il
y a une raison et bien on peut se
coiffer seulement d'une façon avec les
cheveux courvs et avec les chev long on
peut faire des quantités et qu'est-ce
que vous attendez de votre coiffure
vousoulez séduire ou bien vous voulez
simplement avoir un côté disons pratique
simplement dans cette chevelure oh non
pas pratique voule les séduire he toute
femme doit séduire avec sa chevelé
peut-être a sa coiffure surtout
peut-être
merci moi les cheveux courts aussi ma
femme pour les dames vous préférez les
cheveux cours ou les cheveux cour et
surtout je n'aime pas ce gros chignon
qu'on fait sur la tête maintenant ça
c'est affreux ah oui oui je riens que
les chevons c'est plus joli c'est
vraiment très effuminé pour les cheveux
courts cour pourquoi parce que c'est
beaucoup plus pratique plus pratique ah
oui vous avez déjà eu les cheveux longs
oui oui très gênant surtout quand on
porte le manteau à col alors la mode de
1960 vous satisfait beaucoup oui mesdame
excusez-moi de vous interrompre dans
votre promenade je voulais savoir si
vous étiez pour la mode des cheveux
courts ou la mode des cheveux long et
ben moi je porte les cheveux courts pour
la bonne raison que j'ai un bras
invalide autrement j'aimerais mieux les
cheveux longs c'est vrai pourquoi benah
oui je trouve que c'est bien aant et
c'est beaucoup moins cher ah bon on va
moins chez le coiffeur c'est surtout ça
merci Madame voilà je voulais simplement
savoir si vous étiez pour la mode des
cheveux courts ou pour celle des cheveux
long les cheveux courts pourquoi parce
que je trou c'est plus esthétique plus
esthétique oui plus pratique aussi
peut-être non pas plus pratique mais
plus esthétique et les cheveux longs
parce que vous avez les cheveux longs
pour l'instant permettez pas un petit
peu long quoi c'est pas tout à fait non
c'est parce que j'ai pas été cire depuis
je long les cheveux courts pourquoi
parce que je trouve que c'est plus
marrant alors pourquoi vous les avez
long parce que ça me va pas de les avoir
courts moi j'aimerais mieux les cheveux
courts parce que c'est plus pratique
évidemment que les cheveux longs mais
enfin comme les garçons aiment les
cheveux longs alors on est monur que
vous portez les cheveux long oui
pourquoi tu aimes les cheveux longs
parce que parce que c'est plus joli et
tu vourras pas un jour avoir les cheveux
courts non ah non ta maman elle a les
cheveux longs ou les cheveux courts les
cheveux courts les cheveux courts mais
tu l'aimes bien quand même ah
[Musique]
oui je trouve qu'en définitive quand on
a les cheveux courts on peut se coiffer
avec plus de fantaisie et diverses
façons parce que font les cheveux longs
on est toujours réduite soit à porter un
chignon soit à les mettre en tresse
et c'est quand même assez enfin comme de
toute façon on peut pas les porter sur
les épaules parce que parce qu'on a plus
on a plus 15 ou 16 ans hein alors c'est
encore un âge raisonnable pour les port
sur les épaules alors on est obligé de
de se regarder simplement le soir quand
on salle de bain on se dit oui
évidemment j'ai des cheveux longs c'est
très joli mais mais dans la rue pour
sortir au théâtre je trouve que les
cheveux courts amènent beaucoup plus de
fantaisie bien maintenant on est arrivé
à la minute de vérité vous allez sortir
moi je trouve
merci l'homme de votre vie va vous
attendre toujours un homme dans sa vie
il va être très surpris il va vous dire
tiens tu as les cheveux courts
alors'est-ce que vous allez faire
qu'est-ce que vous allez
dire je bienardemoi
bien